Moria brennt es sind Bilder die die Welt
erschüttern zurück bleiben Schutt Asche
und ein
Versprechen nie wieder Moria heißt es
als das neue Lager gebaut wird als
erstes Kamerateam überhaupt dürfen wir
hier drei Tage lang
Drehen eines ist schon erstaunlich wie
schnell Sie dieses Lager jetzt hier aus
dem Boden gestampft haben
und die Frage die wir uns jetzt stellen
ist etwa 1500 Menschen sollen von den
griechischen Inseln nach Deutschland
geholt werden einige auch von hier nach
welchen Kriterien wird da eigentlich
entschieden wer schafft es auf diese
[Musik]
Liste es ist früher Morgen kurz vor der
Landung schon vom Flugzeug aus kann man
es sehen das neue Lager von Lesbos
ein zweites Moria nenn es jetzt schon
viele es sei sogar schlimmer als das
Lager
zuvor ich will mir selbst einen Eindruck
machen will rausfinden wie es den
Menschen hier
geht unsere Anfrage im Camp zu Filmen
aber wurde abgelehnt und dass wir hier
draußen drehen wird offenbar auch nicht
gerne
[Musik]
gesehen was ist denn die Begründung
das kann Ihnen der da erklären aber sie
sind doch hier
verantwortlich die Anspannung bei allen
scheint extrem groß innerhalb nur
weniger Tage wurde dieses hilfslager
aufgebaut die Angst vor negativen
Schlagzeilen und den falschen Bildern
ist riesig dazu die Sorge vor Corona
Fiebermessen direkt am Eingang für
Verdachtsfälle und positiv getestete
gibt es einen eigenen abgesperrten
Quarantänebereich auf einmal dürfen wir
dann doch rein eine spontane Laune des
zuständigen
ministeriumsmitarbeiters bin ehrlich
gesagt total überrascht dass wir uns
jetzt hier reingelassen haben weil nach
allem was sie mir bis jetzt gesagt haben
gab es bislang nur eine einzige
offizielle presseführung hier durch das
Camp mein erster Eindruck überrascht
mich nichts erinnert an das Chaos des
alten Lagers auch die Bilder der
tausenden Obdachlosen nach dem Brand
scheinen weit weg und doch ist klar es
könnte kaum eine schlechteren Ort geben
nirgends Schatten nirgends Schutz vor
Sonne Regen oder sogar
Sturm kein fließend
Wasser kaum Strom und null
Privatsphäre das krasse ist ja dass das
hier ehemaliger truenübungsplatz ist und
V die Hilfsorganisation vermuten dass
hier auch noch Munition liegt wenn man
sich die ganzen Kinder anschaut hier
spielen
dann fragt man sich wirklich was was da
alles passieren
kann schnell spricht sich rum dass wir
aus Deutschland kommen wir werden
umringt von Menschen die uns Ihre
Unterlagen zeigen wollen vor allem von
Jass unserem producer der F und Arabis
spricht erhoffen sie sich
Hilfe das ist interessant das ist einest
aus dem Krankenhaus dasag die Krankheit
von den Lebensumständen hier
kommt mein Bruder ist sehr krank
Deutschland hat doch gesagt dass es
Menschen aufnehmen wird die Hilfe
brauchen warum nehmen Sie ihn nicht auf
hier das sind seine
Papiere ich merke die Verunsicherung ist
riesig jeder hier kennt das Versprechen
aus Deutschland geflüchtete von den
Inseln zu holen die große Frage von
allen wen von uns nimmt ihr
auf also keiner versteht hier na wel
Kriterien w Papiere die sie nicht
verstehen die ihnen keiner übersetzt hat
viele erzählen von ihren kranken
Verwandten oder davon dass sie selber
krank sind und haben irgendwie die
Hoffnung dass sie jetzt raus können weil
sie gehört haben dass Deutschland eben
1500 Migranten aufnehmen
wird aber wird es eine dieser Familien
tatsächlich auf die deutsche Liste
schaffen wir lernen gulam Jafari kennen
zusammen mit seiner Frau und den beiden
Kindern ist er aus Afghanistan
geflüchtet sie nehmen uns mit in ihr
Zelt knapp 5 Quadratmeter für vier
Personen ein paar Matten auf dem Boden
und zwei Taschen voller Kleiderspenden
und Medikamenten für den kranken Sohn
alles was ihnen sonst gehörte ist in
Moria
verbrannt als wir wach wurden war das
Feuer schon direkt vor unserer Tür wir
konnten nichts mehr mitnehmen wir haben
nur noch die Kinder gepackt und das hier
das wichtigste unsere Papiere اینم که از
خب بلند شدگفتیم در اینجا رفیمری
خبود
das ist alles was wir noch
besitzen wie lange sie hier im neuen
Lager bleiben sollen das hat golam und
Fatima keiner
gesagt wir versuchen rauszufinden was
die Papiere bedeuten die ihnen die
Behörden ausgestellt
haben keiner hat euch also erklärt was
das
bedeutet wir haben um eine Übersetzung
gebeten aber sie durften uns nichts
sagen sie haben diese Papiere bekommen
ih wurde nur gesagt dass dieser Barcode
total wichtig ist dass sie drauf
aufpassen sollen und sie wissen aber
überhaupt nicht wofür das jetzt wirklich
ist
und die Vermutung ist dass das
tatsächlich jetzt die Dokumente sind die
Ihnen möglicherweise erlauben die Insel
zu verlassen wohin auch immer aber Sie
wissen
nicht kannst du sie noch mal fragen es
hat ihn wirklich keiner erklärt was
diese Papiere
bedeuten wir haben überall rumgefragt
hier im Camp und alle meinten könnte ein
Hinweis sein dass wir jetzt einen Pass
bekommen und seit hoffen wir jeden Tag
dass wir hier weg dürfen ob es wirklich
klappt werden wir erst später
erfahren erst nehmen mich golam und
Fatima mit in das alte abgebrannte Lager
von
Moria es ist das erste Mal dass die
Familie seit dem Brand wieder hier ist
der Geruch ist schwer auszuhalten
Überreste verbrannter Tiere Verwesung
überall
schau mal die geschmolzenen
Wasserflaschen egal wie viele Bilder man
von diesem Brand schon gesehen hat aber
wenn man dies Besteck hier findet und
das ganze diese ganzen Küchenutensilien
dann ist ir ein komisches
Gefühl
golam und Fatima führen mich zu ihrer
völlig ausgebrannten
Hütte noch immer hätten die Kinder Angst
und Albträume von der Nacht erzählt mir
Fatima und Mohammed der Sohn zeigt uns
die Bilder von Brand auf seinem
Handy Feuer war gleichzeitig an
verschiedenen Stellen im Camp
ausgebrochen schnell stand fest jemand
muss es absichtlich gelegt
haben auch die Familie weiß die
mutmaßlichen Brandstifter waren junge
Afghanen deren Asylanträge abgelehnt
worden
waren unser Nachbar hat gegen die Tür
getreten das Feuer war schon überall
eine unglaubliche
hittze wir sind da raus in den Wald wir
hatten furchtbare Angst dass alle
sterben
und dann findet die fünfjährige Baha
mitten in der Asche doch noch etwas das
ihr gehört zwei verbrannte Murmeln es
ist das einzige was sie aus ihrem alten
Leben geblieben
ist und während über dem abgebrannten
Lager von Moria die Sonne untergeht
frage ich mich welche Spuren all das
wohl hinterlässt das Leben in
permanenter Unsicherheit und dass auch
Eltern ihren Kindern keine Antwort geben
können was der nächste Tag wohl
bringt zurück im Camp der Morgen danach
heute Abend soll eine fre über 800
MigrantInnen von Lesbos aufs Festland
bringen wir treffen Spiros hagabimana
von der griechischen
Einwanderungsbehörde von ihm wollen wir
wissen ob golam Fatima und die Kinder
dabei
sind wir sind dabei die Menschen zu
informieren unsere Leute hier arbeiten
jeden Tag daran aber mir wäre lieber
gewesen Deutschland hätte einfach still
und leise die Leute hier von der Insel
geholt diese große Ankündigung macht uns
sehr viele Probleme es führt zu
Hoffnungen die wir nicht erfüllen können
und zu neuen fluchtwen es gibt sogar
Leute die extra vom Festland wieder nach
Lesbos zurückkommen nur um es auf die
deutsche Liste zu
schaffen
mir wird klar über das deutsche
hilfsversprechen die geflüchteten von
der Insel zu holen hat sich niemand der
Verantwortlichen hier gefreut gut
gemeint sei das zwar im Lager aber
verstärke es vor allem die
Spannungen dass die Menschen so spät
informiert werden sei deshalb auch eine
Sicherheitsmaßnahme erklärt uns biros
noch man wolle Übergriffe durch andere
abgelehnte und enttäuschte
kampbewohnerinnen
verhindern okay ich bin ein Schritt
weiter es gibt dies diese Liste
tatsächlich er hat die Liste auf seinem
Telefon mit allen Namen drauf aber er
kann sie uns nicht zeigen und ob unsere
Familie drauf ist wissen wir immer noch
nicht
genau ich versuche es also weiter Astrid
castelin leitet das flüchtlingshilfswerk
auf Lesbos hier in diesem Zelt erzählt
sie mir sitzen sie und das Team seit
Tagen um an der Liste für Deutschland zu
arbeiten Familien vor allem werden
gesucht deren Asylantrag schon anerkannt
ist alleinreisende Männer dagegen
habenum eine
Chance stehen denn alle
1553 Namen auf der Liste inzwischen
fest die meisten auf der Liste kommen
hier von Lesbos wir machen heute nur
noch die
Feinabstimmung und muss Deutschland an
dieser Auswahl noch zustimmen wenn ich
es richtig verstanden habe kommt aus
Deutschland noch mal eine Delegation für
Befragungen die Namen darf uns auch
Astrid Kast nicht verraten dass sie die
Kriterien aber nicht immer ganz
nachvollziehbar findet das wird
deutlich ich denke es wäre wichtig dass
wir diejenigen priorisieren die den
meisten Schutz brauchen unabhängig davon
ob es Familien sind oder auch allein
reisende Frauen oder
Männer als ich mir diese Männer anschaue
frage ich mich ob sie das alles auch
wissen dass sie eigentlich keine Chance
haben es auf irgendeine Liste zu
schaffen weil sie das Pech haben allein
zu sein ohne Familie und ich frage mich
zu welchen Spannungen das alles hier
noch führen
wird es ist kurz nach 11 Uhr mittags als
wir doch noch eine Familie finden da
sind wir stehen die auf der
Liste Abdel Nasir undadif nusrad mit
ihren beiden Kindern auch sie aus
Afghanistan seit mehr als zi Jahren ist
die Familie auf der Flucht den Reis
hatteadife extra heute früh noch
eingeweicht um ih heute Abend zu kochen
jetzt wird das Abschiedsgeschenk für den
Nachbarn sind heute morgen um 9 Uhr
informiert worden dass ihre Sachen
packen sollen dass sie um 1 Uhr hier
abgeholt werden was hat ih keiner gesagt
wo sie hingebracht werden oder wie es
jetzt
weitergeht was glaubt ihr denn wo es
hingeht vielleicht bringen sie uns nach
Athen aber wir wissen es
nicht und wo wollt ihr hin wir hoffen
wir kommen am Ende nach
Deutschland dann heißt es Abschied
nehmen der Albtraum Moria hat sie
zusammengeschweißt jetzt trennen sich
ihre
Wege Spannungen oder Missgunst erlebe
ich hier nicht stattdessen Freude und
Erleichterung dass es zumindest die
Nachbarn nach Monaten endlich von der
Insel
[Musik]
schaffen es ist eine schlimme Zeit hier
für uns meine Kinder sind krank was für
ein Glück dass wenigstens sie gehen
könn
ich freue mich so für euch dass ihr hier
wegkommt zufällig kommt in dem Moment
auch golam vorbei gibt es irgendwas
neues nein ich habe nichts
gehört auch krass wenn man so ein
bisschen mitgefiebert hat mit denen und
jetzt klar ist dass die hier bleiben
müssen undr
zurü
und die Kinder auf den Weg zur
[Musik]
fre auch die Nachbarn helfen beim
Tragen wir sind so froh dass wir hier
weg
dürfen und auch wir müssen uns hier
verabschieden zum Bus dürfen wir nicht
mit und auch am Hafen keine Erlaubnis
mehr zum
Dreh es bleibt nur ein letztes Winken
aus der Ferne und eine Nachricht die uns
Abdel Nasir am frühen Morgen vom Handy
schickt guten Morgen es ist 6 Uhr und
wir wissen jetzt zumindest sie bringen
uns erstmal in die Nähe von
Athen